bassem des centaines de manifestants
réunis cet après midi aux abords du
parlement
effectivement du bric et on a même
dépassé plus de milliers de manifestants
qui sont toujours aux abords du
parlement le parlement au palais du
bardo où siègent actuellement elle les
parlementaires en vue de ce vote de
confiance très attendu ce soir à l'issue
de ce remaniement ministériel le premier
ministre ni chichis doit présenter ses
nouveaux ministres
hier déjà le président de la république
s'est adressé à la nation pour calmer
les tensions que connaît la tunisie la
capitale principalement et de nombreux
pays à travers de nombreuses villes par
des traverses tout pays il a essayé de
calmer les tensions
on expliquait que le web en faisait son
maximum pour répondre aux revendications
de la population et il a eu un mot
concernant ce remaniement ministériel a
dit ne pas être complètement d'accord
avec son premier ministre
il a reconnu quelques ministres qui a
jugé corrompu et a regretté qu'il n'y
ait pas assez de femmes dans ce nouveau
dans cette nouvelle composition de la
population et à que toujours aux abords
du parlement aux protestations ont
commencé déjà depuis le 14 janvier le
premier jour du confinement qui aurait
duré quatre jours et qui avait créé la
colère car ce premier jour aucun
incident avec l'anniversaire des dix ans
de la révolution et des slogans bien sûr
hostiles à la police mais surtout
hostiles au gouvernement et lui demande
la refonte du tout le système politique
jugé insatisfaisant et et une jugés
inqualifiables projet la situation de
crise dans laquelle la tunisie se trouve
actuellement et bien sûr le parti au
pouvoir le parti ennahda qui est
catalogué et puis tu rendus responsables
de la situation de crise économique vit
actuellement la tunisie sa mère la
situation sanitaire est préoccupante en
tunisie alors qu'elle confine on vient
d'être levée quelles sont les nouvelles
mesures prises par le gouvernement
effectivement la situation sanitaire est
toujours aussi préoccupante ici en
tunisie et puis une des raisons de ces
de ces soulèvements réside également sur
les restrictions imposées par le
gouvernement dans le cadre de la lutte
contre le coc vite et 19 et surtout
cette deuxième vague de propagation du
coronavirus parce que plomb ou prononcer
actuellement c'est que les hôpitaux sont
surchargés certains hôpitaux de fortune
ont été créés partement pays pour
pouvoir pallier à ce manque de
place et puis c'est toujours insuffisant
100 % des places en réanimation sont
occupés la tunisie attend toujours un
vaccin des négociations qui ont été
faites à quel laboratoire sanofi et
fighter qui devrait notamment aboutir
d'ici masse et puis il ya eu une
rencontre entre le ministre des affaires
étrangères le ministre la santé et
l'ambassadeur de russie en tunisie pour
l'acquisition potentielle du vaccin
spoutnik b et c sont encore des
négociations la tunisie a arrêté se
confinant généralisée mais le couvre-feu
est toujours de rigueur à partir de 20
heures les écoles elles ont ouvert les
commerces et restaurants ou cafés aux
cimes avec une capacité de 30 %
déplacements entre les régions interdite
voilà les mesures qui ont été adoptées
par le gouvernement et pourtant ça ne
suffit pas à calmer la tension une
tension qui était d'un point de vue
sanitaire et qu'ils ont ajouté aux
tensions sociales économiques que
traverse le pays actuellement
merci ben hassen chébili pour toutes ces
précisions en direct de tunis